the iPhone 15 Ultra is going to be an
absolutely insane upgrade and I know the
title of this video probably makes me
think that I am insane because of the
chaos going on at Apple right now that's
gonna lead to this awesome upgrade but
I'm gonna explain everything in this
video and it all starts with this brand
new report that just came out from the
information the iPhone 14 pro faced
unprecedented setback leading to removal
of new graphics processor and here's
where we get into the chaos that makes
everything that's been happening over
the last couple years finally makes
sense the information claimed that Apple
Engineers were too ambitious in adding
new features to the graphics processor
designed for the iPhone 14 pro including
features like Ray tracing so basically
when Apple was testing out this brand
new GPU design and the 14 Pros a16
bionic chip they found that it was
drawing too much power impacting the
devices battery life and thermal
management so they basically had to
scrap it at the last moment and hastily
pivot and revert largely back to the GPU
from the a15 bionic chip from last
year's iPhone 13 lineup and that's
basically why we didn't see that big of
a performance Improvement specifically
you can look at our video where we
compared the 14 pro Max versus 13 Pro
Max check out that difference if I punch
this really quickly into the calculator
you could see only seven percent
Improvement in Metal Graphics score from
the a15 to the a16 with the 5 Core GPU
that is incredibly small for an apple a
series chip but getting back to the
article this incident is reportedly
unprecedented in Apple's ship design
history and it's responsible for why the
iPhone 14 pro shows only small
improvements and graph graphics
performance compared to leaps made by
previous iPhone Generations like I just
showed you and unfortunately here's
where the chaos comes in the era
resulted in apple restructuring its
graphics processor team and moving some
managers away from the project including
the exit of key figures that apparently
contributed to Apple's emergence as a
chip design leader that is so
unfortunate and I don't know if you've
been seeing the recent reports over the
last couple of years but many people
from Apple's chip team have been leaving
so basically because of all of that we
are left with a stop Gap a16 bionic chip
and what that means is that it's
essentially just the same ship that's
refined retuned overclocked and I can
prove it to you right here as you can
see on geeker one's YouTube channel we
have an 8.1 percent performance
improvement from the a15 to the a16 in
terms of single core performance but you
know why that happened because they
increased the clock speed by exactly 8.1
percent yes all they needed to do was
overclocked the performance cores for
that Improvement that's all they did
it's a stop Gap now wait I do have to
take that back a little bit because the
actual power draw improved quite a bit
on the a16 and that's because of the
four nanometer process which is
essentially just enhanced five nanometer
it's really not true for a nanometers so
they did do a good job with lowering the
power usage of the a16 chip which likely
allowed them to be able to overclock it
that much now to prove it to you even
further check out their gfx bench 5.0
GPU test and as you can see they have
essentially the same graphics
performance and this host from geeker
one literally says this is the first
time in history of a series processors
that the GPU has not improved at all
especially in this gfx bench test so
basically the a16 is a stop Gap chip and
the most worrying part about all of this
before I get into the Silver Lining is
the fact that the competition over on
the Android side has a chance to catch
up but thankfully even the new
Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 doesn't get close to
beating out the new a16 bionic from
Apple as you can see 2500 to 2600 points
in 3D Marks Wildlife extreme compared to
3 310 and this is a test from Technic
and then this test we actually have a
battery drain test running multiple and
2-2 Benchmark runs and as you can see
the iPhone 14 pro Max with the a16
bionic only lost 17 battery life
compared to 26 and 25 with these
Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 and the 8 plus gen 1
so that's good news so the a16 chip is
thankfully still on top even with
stop Gap a16 ship it is still scoring
higher than the competition and now
let's finally get into the silver lining
for the iPhone 15 Ultra the fact that
apple had all of that chaos and they had
to delay the brand new GPU design at the
last minute means that this new GPU that
Apple worked on will likely debut on the
brand new three nanometer process node
from tsmc with the a17 chip so what this
means is that we're not only going to
have huge gains from the new GPU design
but we're also going to get huge gains
from three nanometer at the same time
combined into one chip generation
Improvement but way it actually gets
even better because we're not only
getting this brand new a17 chip which is
going to be killer but we're also
getting a new redesign with a titanium
chassis with curved rear edges on the
iPhone 15 lineup so we're basically
getting that three-year redesign that
happened with the iPhone 12. it's now
going to happen with the iPhone 15 again
so that's going to be a big deal but
even better we're expecting USBC ports
on the iPhone 15 lineup as well and
maybe even much faster speeds for the 15
Pros so I believe that this new iPhone
15 Ultra is going to be a super cycle
upgrade it is going to be amazing
because we're not only getting a brand
new design we're finally getting USBC
which people have been asking for for
years and we're getting years of Chip
growth that has been stalled finally
getting Unleashed with the a17 chip and
that's all happening at the same time in
one major release so I think the iPhone
phone 15 Ultra is going to be absolutely
insane and once again it's all thanks to
the chaos and delays over at Apple we've
got to thank them for that and hopefully
they're gonna have even more time to
refine that new GPU since they had to
delay it make it even better in time for
the a17 so if you disagree with anything
in this video let me know down in the
comment section below but if you enjoyed
it click the circle button to subscribe
and if you're looking for a new iPhone
right now you don't want to wait for the
15 Ultra then use the YouTube product
tagging feature below to check one out
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
foreign
[Music]